[Music]
in this video we will learn how to
deploy google's external https load
balancer with terraform
first let's have a quick overview of
https load balancers
google cloud offers global and regional
https load balancing with internal and
external ip addresses
these load balancers scale as the users
and traffic grow thus providing seamless
auto scaling
they can balance http and https traffic
across multiple backend instances across
multiple regions
now let's understand what terraform is
terraform is an infrastructure as a code
tool that automates the provisioning and
management of infrastructure
it allows users to define infrastructure
in human readable configuration files
that can be easily versioned reused and
shared
terraform is a platform agnostic tool
that is it can be used across any
supported provider
it accomplishes this by interacting with
the apis of cloud providers
now we will look at the benefits of
terraform
terraform can manage infrastructure on
multiple cloud platforms such as google
cloud platform or gcp azure and aws just
to name a few
the human readable configuration
language helps you write infrastructure
code quickly
it allows you to track infrastructure
changes through version control
in today's demo we will focus on how to
deploy an external https load balancer
that forwards traffic to two google
compute engine virtual machines
created as part of instance group 1
and instance group 2 in u.s best 1 and
u.s east 1 regions with terraform
before we deploy the load balancer with
terraform ensure that the terraform
service account used for deploying the
resources has the relevant iem
permissions
here are the required rules
compute load balancer admin role
compute network admin role
compute security admin role
and compute instance admin role
now it's time for the demo
open cloud shell and set the project
using gcloud config where you want to
deploy the resources
note
terraform is integrated with cloud shell
and cloud shell automatically
authenticates terraform letting you get
started with less setup
navigate to the directory where the
terraform script is located
in our example the terraform script is
located under directory home test cloud
shell underscore open
terraform hyphen google hyphen lb hyphen
http
next step is to initialize the working
directory with terraform init command
it initializes the working directory
containing terraform configuration files
it also performs several different
initialization steps to prepare a
working directory for use
now let's look at the terraform script
main.tf
in this script we have defined the
resources we want to deploy global
forwarding rule
multiple manage instance groups and url
map
finally
run terraform apply to execute the
script and deploy the resources
let's now validate if all the resources
are created successfully and we are able
to access the load balancer ip
in the google cloud console go to the
load balancing page and validate that
the load balancer resource is created
in our example you can see the load
balancer multi hyphen make hyphen lb
hyphen http hyphen url hyphen map is
created
click on load balancer and verify that
the back-ends are healthy
great we can see all the back-ends are
healthy
click on back-ends to verify that there
are two instance groups one each in the
u.s east one and u.s west 1 region
access load balancer ip by navigating to
http
34.111.126.202 from your browser and
validate that you are able to access the
backends
congratulations
we have successfully created an external
https load balancer with terraform and
verified that all the resources are
created and the load balancer is
accessible
check out this documentation for sample
terraform scripts that can be used to
deploy external https load balancers for
your preferred backend type
[Music]
you